oh hello I'm Anthony Daniels and this is
every version of c-3po from the Star
Wars movies plans what are you talking
about
[Music]
[Applause]
you know I am famous for having turned
down the opportunity to be in Star Wars
back in 1975 I hadn't wanted to meet a
director called George Lucas but I did
but it wasn't interested in his sci-fi
movie until I saw Ralph McQuarrie's
conceptual artwork of the character he
had created this Android figure that was
standing looking out of the frame
towards me and really connected I fell
in love with it I slightly think
Swee'Pea fell in love with me but I'm
not sure the concept of the character
was actually based on a film from way
back in time metropolis by Fritz Lang
and in that film the the powers that be
created a fake human to try and
encourage the workers to behave and
George had brought McQuarrie create
something similar the similarity would
be that neither of us the original actor
Hoel myself could actually move in these
costumes very well when I read the
script I really like c-3po so I was very
very happy to go the next day to Elstree
Studios in North London and be cast for
the part and I don't mean did I get the
part no I mean that I was actually
covered in plaster to make a mold of my
body that would be the frame to make the
actual robot suit well I have to tell
you that being cast in plaster is not
something I would recommend especially
the day where they shot straws up your
nose so that they can model your head
eventually they're in the studio was my
figure in white plaster with very little
clothing on it wasn't a pretty sight but
then came along Lismore the sculptor
over the next few weeks
Liz began to cover my white body with
gray modeling clay and she built up the
shape that you eventually see
in the finish figure all these little
lines and curly cues and shapes were a
reference to that Fritz Lang movie I'd
be in the studio most days and they
would try out a new piece on me it might
be an arm or a leg or a neck or head or
or something and sometimes they were
paper prototypes sometimes there's a
plastic thin plastic the most
interesting thing for me was was when it
came to through PIOs face I remember
coming into a room and there were I
think six heads on the kind of high
table and actually they were all
terrific in in their gray clay there was
this one and I said to George this is
the only one I don't like is this one at
the end is it that's one we're using in
my defense he didn't look anything like
he turned out because when he turned out
in gold
I felt Threepio it was beautiful there's
no way Threepio can ever exist without a
whole team and that was right from the
beginning
first of all across George Lucas who
thought of the idea
Norman Reynolds and then down to Phil
McDonald Maxie my dresser who was not
from the wardrobe department but from
props because basically I was a prop
Maxie and his his fellow workers would
join in a team because I needed more
than Maxie it turned out it was way more
complicated to costume than anybody
thought and so on that first day I think
there were six people coming in from all
angles to dress me up in it and I really
rely and have always relied on the
kindness of the crew and the people who
really care about making me as
comfortable as long as possible which
wasn't
that gradually they built up the team
under Norman Reynolds who worked with a
plasters Department and the plastics
department all these clever prop makers
and they came up eventually with all the
bits and pieces to make a robot and I
tried it on in the special effects
studio at Elstree and for the first time
I had that suit in its entirety around
me it was horrible I had completely lost
connectivity with my body the world
I literally blundered around the studio
because I couldn't really see about the
eyes in the center and I had no idea
what my elbows were doing which were way
bigger than my elbows my shoulders were
bigger
my legs were kind of trapped after about
15 minutes we took it off relief I never
saw it again until a month later they're
out in a tent in the desert and there
were all the pieces seventeen pieces I
think laid out and gradually over a two
hour period they covered me in this gold
we started off with lack tights and a
black leotard and a black hood the next
bit would be slightly more sensitive
area the front and the back and these
were two pieces of very thin plastic to
be in vacuum-formed and they put these
around me and over the course of thing
then they took gold tape and stuck that
down the side so now the two parts front
and back had become one next really
complicated there was the top half of
the leg that was attached to the bottom
of the calf with a sort of well
literally a bungee cord either side that
stretched down between two nodules
this allowed the the piece to work like
that to keep them locked together with
the knee which had these kind of
interlocking fragments like that
they came down and to get that on Maxie
my dresser in the team turned it the
wrong way I put my foot through it all
the way down and then when it was in
there they turned it round and pinned
the back on so now my leg was locked in
there before that they they put on my
deck shoe a deck shoe being a little
rubber soled canvas thing with the kind
of white rum around there and nice blue
canvas top sort of thing you'd wear if
you were out sailing but here we weren't
this was mainly the under shoe because
the top of three POS foot was all the
foot there was it was just a foot bang a
gold cover that looked beautiful again
made out of very thin plastic and then
we came up to the top section the front
and the back I was locked in there I
wasn't going anywhere we'd had this suit
then an arm came up I had black cotton
gloves on as well and then a hand and
these were strange pieces of just
knuckles and joints and things glued
onto black cotton gloves Maxie had glued
them on the night before the glue had
said before we could take them off and
basically we had to wrench them off my
hands for me to go to sleep that night
we had two necks one was split down the
back and pinned together and that was
for the camera to shoot from the front
the other one was for the camera to
shoot from the back and that had a split
on the front I know stay with me I think
we've been two hours doing this hour and
a half at least
then came the final torture which was to
take the face and the back almost like
an easter egg
cut in half right put them together like
that and here's the clever bit
mother seemed a good idea at the time
they took the kind of earring thing here
and they pointed it through the hole in
the side of the face which joined to the
hole in the back of the head and then
hoped it through into a bayonet fitting
like a lightbulb out of action light bar
in the neck trouble was that this was
quite hard on the day because you had to
lighten up these holes and the pin and
push against something that pushed away
when you pushed it after half an hour
I'm not exaggerating they finally long
these pins into shape and at which point
they the same banner tight-fitting but
far easier just to pieces so we had the
whole Threepio look and that first day
when I walked out into the desert nobody
had ever seen that that shape that
figure before and through the little
pinhole eyes I could scan all the people
in front of me the crew who were
standing as there as the Morning Sun
rose up over the desert and their
reaction was extraordinary
they were variously either very charmed
or completely crazy
they just Wow look at that sort of thing
and finally Threepio was complete apart
from one thing
that Maxie put his hand up behind 3p O's
back and under that little backplate
there's a tiny swish that connected the
six batteries within that little box to
a wire that came over inside my head
that had been joined to another wire
which was connected to the eyes so we
had a full circuit from those little
eyes and so with a flick of the switch
suddenly Threepio had become alive for
the very first time
my friend c-3po of course looks
fantastic but there was one thing that
at that point was missing because one of
three pios attributes he loves to talk
use the translator fluent in over six
million forms of communication how was
this going to happen I'd had six months
to think I don't know I'm only a droid
and not very knowledgeable about such
things so here was day one and I still
didn't know what was gonna happen what
was I gonna do I was there in the desert
I was hurting I was pain I had learnt
the words sort of I never been in a film
so the word action was terrifying quite
terrifying but at that moment something
came to my aid some kind of movie magic
some kind of force whatever because at
that moment that precise moment Threepio
came alive by sir my first job was
programming binary load it is very
similar to your vaporators in most
respects
can you speak bocce of course I can say
it's like a second language to me I miss
all right I couldn't say it on the day I
think that my nervousness my
discombobulation of everything made me
flub the lines like crazy third time I
got it wrong George kind of frowned and
walked over instead
Threepio in the eye and therefore me in
the eye you can say anything you like
don't worry about the voice I can fix it
later I was embarrassed because there's
an actor I like to get the lines right
so then I carried on and in that case on
the fourth take I said my said my first
job was ba-ba-ba-ba-ba what to bring cut
of course George knew that he could put
in a proper voice later because when
your head is inside a bucket you don't
sound so good that sounded horrible
Cobra because we possibly used that kind
of vocal quality even though the
microphone was here and a little
microphone cable was going all the way
down my back into my pants those two
bits of plastic start together and the
transmitter was shot somewhere really
quite
warm yes I was speaking to you all the
time out of my butt the huge success of
a new hope meant that suddenly we were
making a second film The Empire Strikes
Back number 5 I know the math has always
confused me a bit but Threepio was back
there again and now people that had a
chance to kind of study the cost him a
little more some things were changed to
make things easier for the Empire
Strikes Back the the question was basic
and the same and some of the
improvements maybe save time but it was
still a struggle to to be c-3po the
shoes were one piece they were no longer
the deck shoes with the cover they were
opened at the back and my foot went in
and then believe it or not again with
the gold tape they were too taped up
tied sometimes with shoe laces
one thing I want to remind you of back
in the day in Episode four
Threepio didn't have two gold legs he
had won silver shin a lot of people
didn't notice it and the reason is it
was kind of subtle and the silver
actually reflected the gold of the other
and also in the desert it reflected the
gold of the sand to certain extent that
John Jay the beloved stills photographer
nipping shooting stills all through the
shoot on the last day in the desert he
came up to say times why are you wearing
a silver leg today and I thought I'm
blind cameraman I've got to rest before
I fall apart my joints are almost frozen
people still argue does Rubio have a
silver leg the point of the silver shin
that would come to haunt me many years
later in the force awakens was to say
that Threepio had had a bit of a history
that he'd had some kind of drama before
this you know and but it was so subtle
that hardly anybody noticed the Threepio
was there and still fairly mobile
I had in fact been tap-dancing on the
Muppet Show just a few months before but
again I I was younger certainly don't
know but this is our beginning the world
right for The Empire Strikes Back I also
had well Threepio had new hands they
still didn't work but there were new and
they were one piece plastic very much
looked like the originals but have been
made on a new mold and split open under
here and I would wiggle my hand in
wearing a black glove too you know
wearing plastic on your skin is not nice
so the glove was still essential just as
a cover me on the inside so now I had
these beautiful plastic gloves that were
this shape and whatever I did they
remained this shape it was like curse of
the plastic hands you can do and my
joints are freezing out eventually they
they would soften with body heat and so
on said that it could with pressure bend
them like this if I wanted to point over
there I would by the side of my body
curl these fingers around hold them
against my body with my finger extended
and then at the last minute on cue go oh
look I think if I stay there much longer
you know they were not great again the
wrong materials or different everyone
was trying this is not a criticism it's
a list of facts okay the pants section
as well call them those two originally
were in two pieces the second film these
were one piece and they were we remade
we made a little casting and this part
of my body hit by now I was I was in
urine to the humiliation and things
actors have to go through to key to keep
apart you know and so they they made
this kind of little mini section statue
at me and then cast that in a kind of
heavier rubbery plastic which meant that
it was one piece so you couldn't just
wrap it around me I had to wiggle into
it
and again a rather kind of undignified
wiggling motion if you study c-3po
close-up freeze-frame and look at
various parts of his body there are wear
marks this machine I guess you get that
anyway but if you look here you'll see
that within moments the gold finish
because it was a paint you see there are
score marks here with the painter
totally gone absolutely no it's grey
metals aluminum here this is difficult
for the team because they need to find a
gold finish that were detached with
plastic which was semi semi mobile so
again you'll see all sorts of flaking
but the overall effect as the movie
sweeps by you know sealing this stuff
you don't want to see you're not looking
for that you're looking for the whole
story of the gold character that's going
on these adventures with his friends
there were a lot of fun things in the
Empire Strikes Back but the scary thing
and the fun thing was reading on the
page
Threepio in Cloud City something's going
on in this Scientology oh so he goes in
and you hear him say oh I was out of a
job
i scurried through the next few pages he
wasn't dead yet he wasn't finished
Chewbacca went and found bits of
Threepio as they headed towards the
fiery furnace of meltdown one of his
great dress Chewbacca was there to drag
him and put him in his bits and in there
and so now three BIOS performance my
performance was it in pieces literally
in pieces Mayhew who was Chewbacca at
the time had a bag of bits and I've got
to tell you that if you look carefully
some fan has just discovered there's an
arm and a leg and a other bit nervous in
the valley in fact there are two arms
both right arms
got it wrong love it because I had all
sorts of spare bits and they just
chucked bits in there and didn't notice
that they had two right arms anyone
alone had to be a mistake
you've got to forget them and the clever
thing there was Chewbacca Peter Mayhew
he had a blaster and on this end was a
piece of fishing wire attached through
the costume to this so when he did that
my head on the back was being animated
by a fishing wire so get the whole thing
alive the more fun was when he put my
head on backwards only way to do it was
to take a Threepio head cut out the back
of the head so his face was here looking
that way my face was sticking out of the
back which from the side is a bit
difficult because this bits longer
especially this bit so this vide 'king
out to the side so they stuck gold tape
on it and I promise you if you freeze
frame in that video on three on
Chewbacca's knee you will see for a
moment a kind of thing here and that is
my nose something not everything is
perfect in Star Wars not everything is
photoshopped out there's little moments
but then there were other moments that I
would be on the floor with my arm up
through the Threepio chest into the face
so that I could animate it a bit like an
old ventriloquist puppet as I spoke the
line so I could animate as I spoke and
when you put them together the audience
believes it's one phenomena the scariest
bit for me was with Threepio is standing
in the middle of the fork and corridor
and he's holding a limb
you didn't have to fix the hyperdrive
Chewbacca could do it down there the leg
is missing now these days you do it with
green screen technology adjusting your
clever computer stuff then no it was me
standing on one leg with my other leg
curled up behind me so in line with the
camera so you couldn't see it and
holding this and balancing and speaking
and shouting I'm standing here in pieces
and you have delusions of grandeur I
managed not to fall over but it was kind
of scary because falling in that costume
is not good so sitting down moment was
even more fun because there's a point
later on where Threepio is sitting on a
box and Artoo's there and he's got a
foot and a welding torch and he in my
book he was saying and I'm saying where
do you think it goes um the three
viewers legs are sticking straight
pretty much out to the camera so how did
we do that how did we have me sitting
footless on a box discussing how to
attach my foot yeah you're right I
wasn't sitting on the Box I was kneeling
on the floor through the box with my
feet coming out of the side pretty much
it is me always in the Threepio suit
although young jim was the one who
actually fell off the cliff when the
sand person attacked Luke Skywalker
[Music]
Jim is making props Department
apparently he was dispensable because if
I'd hurt myself filming would have come
to a halt for a while whereas Jim
wearing bits my costume nobody cared
bang I could have done it it was easy
just out of camera onto a mattress a
bigger stunt was in Return of the Jedi
caviar on Jabba's barge and by now three
psi is hanging out salacious crumbs
fooled it there and I am edging towards
the top of the hand read the handrail
was missing on Jabba's barge and I'm
blindly I mean I'm now seeing one eyed
with restricted vision think about it
and I'm about 60 feet up and as we get
to the rails he cut because I had stood
as though I was going to fall over she
was behind me the motorized artery is
like you're nudging me forward that's
part of the film we get to my fall
position cut and then I relax and then
Tracey Emin stunt person came in and she
was wearing a rubber suit heaven knows
what it felt like and she stood there
and I showed her my hand position and
she took it she stood there and it said
action and she went forward and when you
watch she twists round in the air and
falls out of shock few of England
mattresses and on underneath the
mattresses piles of cardboard boxes and
what they do is absorb the shock bit
like the front of your car and she was
absolutely fine of course she's a pro
she was wonderful here's the thing you
don't know maybe a couple of hours later
she was back up on deck she'd taken off
the rubber suit she was no longer
Threepio she was Princess Leia and she
is the one who sweeps across to the
barge over there to the skiff wonderful
skilled woman dude I guess I won't
mention my name
well it's a real pleasure to meet you of
course not all Star Wars is in the
movies right some of the most amazing
spin-offs have been a great joy to me
and the chief one star to us know in a
kingdom very very near Disneyland if you
haven't had been written starters at one
of the Disney parks I suggest you stop
watching this video and go right now
because it is a superb rendition of the
story in a way that involves you
Threepio is there to welcome you in the
space bordered Disney is there with our
two hottest mending with having ship and
of course getting it totally wrong and
in any blows happen it's a very exciting
night but to do this they needed an
animatronic c-3po
so Tom Fitzgerald the producer the head
of the design team at Imagineers at
Disney it got me into a studio and and
said where he told me the whole story
and I was sold from the moment I heard
it and then he said Penn our idea is for
you to come in this little mock-up said
understand just in new jeans and a shirt
and play the scene c-3po it was kind of
funny we had a camera and I had a
sandbag over one foot and when I lost
why said well that's where all the
engineering for the animatronics comes
up into the frame that is through c-3po
and animates his actions so we need to
if you wouldn't want to keep still on
that leg and we filmed the scene they
recorded my voice and my action so when
our to test the ion cannons and here I
had a console and I was poking buttons
and r2 is helping things blow up and
they were using this as a guide he also
asked me to look at the audience who
were coming in two passengers who were
coming down the space board around
around around and they would be at this
point about Madden oh six feet 8 feet
below me looking up as they went by I
turned in the console and dr. people
and then carried on waters day and of
course the inevitable happened
when I stood there alone in the space
ball before we opened possibly
rehearsing stuff I stood looking up at
3pf thinking just how brilliant Disney
had been in in in making a real robot
out of a fake robot and at that point as
I was kind of admiring he turned and
looked straight at me I'm getting goose
bumps right now many years had passed
after Return of the Jedi and I actually
thought you know Star Wars was never
gonna happen again
I'd got on with life it was okay and
then a phone call would I go and meet
George Lucas Leavesden studios in North
London of course and we had a meeting
about this new film and you said you're
you're created by Anakin yeah you're
built by Anakin he's a kid I just
thought that was brilliant to have the
sweetest character pretty much in the
universe to be made by one of the artist
villains ever so that was cool how it
was achieved was a puppet and the puppet
was built at ILM Industrial Light and
Magic by Michael Lynch one of the prop
makers and designers r2d2 so beautifully
put it you mean Nate he did my part so
sure my it was exquisite was totally
believable as the insides of this and
they they didn't actually offer me the
option of puppeteering it
you know Michael knew how it worked and
it was his thing
I got a service disappointed I would
have liked to have had to go so
basically I was there as the voice often
trying to match movements that weren't
particularly mine but as George said
young it's just been made by a kid what
do you expect not that one that one but
it was a total different dynamic
physical dynamic I accepted it by choice
and I was fascinated by the puppet which
was really heavy and although they tried
to take out as much heavy material but
it's still way not tongue them
intellectually a ton and of course was
extremely realistic you could totally
believe this was the inside so there we
had the first film and obviously if
you're making a prequel you're making
number two a prequel and at this point I
said well you know I'd feel better if if
you'd let me try and puppeteer it
because kind of it's my head my brain my
thought process be careful what you wish
for there I was with Dom Bea's my new
team head leader and Justin Dix who
would come back into the story dressing
up as puppet Threepio now there there's
a Japanese art form theatrical art form
called Bunraku where you have the most
beautiful puppets and they are animated
by performers who were dressed in black
and knew the audience except they're not
there it's fine
it's called suspension of disbelief and
so this creature was attached to my feet
so his his heels were touched my toes
his knees to my knees his waist to my
waist etc and the arms were on the end
of sticks at his elbow so that I could
animate to some extent where he was
touching things the head attached to my
head to a helmet like that
the only trouble was of course that his
face was in front of my face so I
couldn't see I had to guess who I was
looking at another challenge the whole
thing pretty much rested on a heavy
harness like a Steadicam harness
that can take a lot of weight and
distribute it around your frame and I
rehearsed for days in creatures shop
Hatsune Australia and and could walk
pretty pretty well in it and all that
kind of thing I was absolutely ready for
my first shot having the most touching
conversation with padme amidala who in
the middle of the night because she
couldn't sleep was talking calmly and
kindly with Threepio and asking him if
he was happy there and he said well I'm
not unhappy the people are lovely but
being like this like one naked if you'll
pardon the expression it wasn't easy for
him and in this scene you suddenly have
a the inner mind of this beloved droid
who had suffered for 18 years for his
nakedness and of course she in Padme
being very clever so but there's a box
of coverings right here why oh my I
never noticed truly one of the best
lines and I read it when you came back
there's Natalie Portman holding the face
of Threepio and meantime Dom bees had
stuck the back of the head on me and
around here had put fridge magnets I
also had the lights three peers eyes on
a special rig that Don had made a bit
like spectacles so just the eyes and
Natalie on action had to maneuver this
face not quite I think about the 13 she
did it and there was three P oh how as
the shape of three people for the first
time and everybody was exquisitely happy
especially 3ba so right from the
beginning the film we reshot the
Threepio scenes they're happy puppets
happy we shot them on blue screen green
screen any screen with the gold suit
that Justin Dix had done a wonderful
paint job on to make it look rusty so
here's a clue if you ever go up to the
rusty Threepio just scratch a bit and
you see his gold skin underneath the big
difference here was that because he
always started off shiny but their
Georgia seminar he needs
dirted down and kind of made to look
grungy and stuff so he was always a bit
grungy a bit oil covered and covered
indeed not so much in oil but in shoe
polish and table wax in the script I
really didn't have much to do that it
was really concentrating on the decline
and form of my Creator Anakin Skywalker
I mean it was tragic
not the Threepio we would ever find out
and he still doesn't know sir you know
keep the c-3po is Lucas of course iconic
gold a dirty gold to begin with and then
bright shiny gold for episode three but
then came a bit of a twist on this
clever piece of scripting Threepio
suffers an accident in in some kind of
robot factory and he ends up with the
the body of a battle droid
I'm so confused and and to do it what we
did was in fact film me in full Threepio
costume and then they they animated a
suit around me I had a blaster
but again three POS hands were so
difficult to manipulate that they
actually had a wire
the gun wanted me said I could hold it
like that and I learned a fun thing as I
came towards the camera the line was
dying Jedi dogs died I will admit those
weren't the precise words I said because
I'm wanted to get a laugh but what was
interesting is I found that you couldn't
go die Jedi dogs died or whatever words
without going you've got to make the
thing live for you you know and that was
kind of exciting and totally daft
actually c-3po has no memory of it so
it's cool for Revenge of the Sith which
was obviously going to be the final film
they had made the the collar the the
neck a little bigger so that it grated
on me rather less and sort of didn't
constrict my Adam's apple all day it
wasn't nice to wear but in a rather soft
away they'd change the process of the
courser into a silicon which was light
and not exactly breathable but it was
more pleasant than the thick rubber
thing that I had on before so all the
time people were making little
adjustments for my safety in welfare
they're not very grateful and you have a
special standby painter who would come
and dog the costume just to take the
shine off in the camera department had
another trick they go hold your breath
stones and like hairspray in the face
but it was dulling spray because you
don't want that costume to be too shiny
because it reflects everything
but here I was magnificent in shine
eventually I would be at ILM and see
somebody watching frame by frame by
frame every moment that I made and in
Photoshop replacing the green with gold
how amazing that I had thought that
after episode six that was it
Return of the Jedi and no we had the
prequels new word for us all one two
three four five six that was it wrong
hopelessly wrong because of course the
phone call would I care to work with JJ
Abrams he asked me would you just like
to do the voice and I said no but I
would like a new suit of course that's
Jay David Merriweather a total genius in
the special effects science department
constructed a suit for photographs and
any material he could get anything I
could help him with and he came up with
the whole suit exploded on his computer
to die was miraculous absolutely
miraculous a lot of it was the same new
material for the middle piece for the
Panzer section the amazing thing he did
was to insert some pieces here and here
that stopped me being snapped by the
meeting of these two joints but the big
thing this half-hour screw here screw
here became a bag a and
after all these years magic after each
shot take it off put it back on take it
off
transformed my life filming adored
working on that film adored it apart
from one argument right at the beginning
with the director with JJ what's with
the red arm
it shows some history you mean like the
the silver shin in the first film a new
hope
yeah exactly but that was too subtle to
notice exactly that's why it's red I did
not like the red arm okay I thought it
was too big to avert to clumsier jest
yes so every day on the set I would say
to JJ no forgiveness ever he would love
I so persecuted JJ on the set of The
Force awakens about the red arm I gave
him no no water at all and we finished
and that was it and then I go to see the
premiere and I'm looking at this shot
yeah there's the Falcon now rising
through special effects and there is
Threepio waiting
with a gold arm JJ had given me a final
gift
he changed the color in post-production
three POS got a gold on further Force
awakens and indeed for the last Jedi
Threepio it was 3d printed and of course
it makes it easier to prototype because
it's all on a computer and you go
there's not quite right
etc that was fine still Wade surprising
amount actually but the Panzer section
was made of a different material the
kind of new material that was fine and
it was paintable then it moved gradually
it stiffened up the the material didn't
react well with the atmosphere but
gradually as we got towards the end
filming I was really sick realizing how
difficult this was and there was nothing
I could do about it
tried to fudge it try to trick so you
don't notice it so much of course you
will know won't you
part of the the wonder of three PS look
when he is that Brian Gould is that he
doesn't start off that way at all starts
off with just an ordinary plasticky
looking thing white in this case but
then the vacuum plate a silver finish
onto it so you put it in a vacuum
chamber with silver foil and it sticks
to it but then the clever thing so
you've got a silver droid so then the
paint department the art department take
various colored lacquers that cover the
silver but but making it make it gold
and the silver gives it lift and life
and brightness but you need and you need
that if you started with solid gold it
kind of would be a little dead so they
thought this out and he looked
magnificent once the red arm had gone of
course
what joy to be asked to be in road 1 s 3
p.m. he just one scene walkthrough like
Alfred Hitchcock who was that droid yes
I was there it was the same suit of
course but it just Shawn out of that
very dark and forbidding set and there
was 3 p.m. and I I did a little trick I
got fully dressed in my little tent my
easy up tent and when I was ready they
opened the entrance and I walked out
nobody knew I was going to be there it
was a huge secret that Threepio was in
this shot it was a really good moment
but it was soon over and so we come to
the rise of Skywalker what it's all been
about where we were heading and here was
Threepio again - the red arm JJ was
indeed forgiving what a brilliant
fanatically agree but there were
receives with the suit still the fixing
was great the arms the hands for the
first time they made hands that actually
were jointed like my own fingers this is
brilliant it meant that if I wanted to
pick something up I could do and that
was so good in the first in the first
sequence in the sand tunnels with the
dagger oh it's one of those I cannot
tell you what it felt like it was total
freedom back in the day it would be
sorry you know I would have dropped it
here I was catching it looking at it
there were other changes no were not so
good
by now the section that we know what we
call it that material really had
stiffened down it was like wearing
concrete Underpants I had a wonderful
part in that film I had dog being in it
but I had a lot of movement to do a lot
of running about a lot of strange
terrain
made these tunnels judging by the
circumference of the tunnel walls there
and so gradually towards the end when it
became almost impossible to move in that
little section we found ways round him
thank goodness for ILM because we we
were able to do all sorts of sequences
that I couldn't do wearing the full
middle of the suit and indeed when I was
climbing up two arches freighter of that
rock face there was me but but I was
wearing only the as it were girdle part
of the middle section the rest of me
from the hair down was covered in red
dots and for other sequences it was the
same when something was impossible we
took away that bit of the costume stuck
red dots down my legs as reference for
ILM and they drew in three Pio's missing
limbs absolute magic first day and the
rise of Skywalker who is awful I was
delighted to be there with the crew and
Daisy and Oscar and John and of course
JJ but by what I said because the San
tunnels was a very enclosed set it had
to be it was it was a tunnel - and it
was very hot it was hot because we had
lamps in there and also there was
atmosphere a bit of a bit of smoke to
make the lighting look really cool as
opposed to the hotness that it was and
it was real perspiration time and one of
the magic things there done was to give
me a little vest very thin material but
on - it was sewn fine plastic tubes
little thin plastic tubes that circled
like an underfloor heating system except
it wasn't a heating system
it was the cooling system and what
happened at the end of a take was they
would attach me to a black bag very
smart but in it was water with lumps of
ice and in the bag onto a tube was a
circulating fan so would shoot water up
the tubes down the tubes opportune all
around my chest and back
it was fantastic it was immediate it
felt like a heart attack it was really
weird but it did keep me cool could he
take it for so long
young cool now I'm cool totally cool
disconnect me for sitting there in that
terrifying scene the red eyes sitting
down in that costume is not possible so
we went for the full bikini section of
that yes I whispering to this amazing
codpiece the rest of the suit was cut
away so I could sit down and you don't
you don't see it you don't expect to see
it you don't see it maybe if you can
freeze frame and come in zoom it's that
serious about it you'll see the
difference but of course we also had the
red eyes when I first looked in a mirror
at me Threepio with the red eyes
I got to tell you it was it was quite
shocking because he'd never been like
that before we had eyes of different
intensities sometimes they were actually
operated by radio from the electric
system over here that if I was in very
bright light ambient light then they
would need to make the eyes bright so
they were sharp if it was in a gloomy
cave for instance they went dim the
lights so they weren't too piercing so
all the time you've got a crew behind me
adding 2 to 3 peers value as a character
quite amazing but the teamwork that goes
into making bits of the Threepio work on
the whole for the better I can actually
take this moment to say thank you guys
thank you what you
I love remembering how Tracey Emin
played c-3po falling off Jabba's barge
and then how she played Princess Leia
sweeping across the little skiff over
there and stuntpeople actually around a
valued frankly I I've wanted there to be
an Academy Award from for them that it
hasn't happened yet films like mmm the
ones we're talking about really depends
on the stunt people so many time time
after time so I was very very glad to
have a stunt person of my own Michael
birch he was my stunt double but when we
were talking about the wonderful speeder
sequence in in Jordan in Mehsana the
desert magic there were sequences there
was shot on very fast running vehicles
and Mike was there being three pio in
the distance running at 70 miles an hour
and in case the car crashed he was not
allowed to be roped on he had to have
the ability to freefall off the vehicle
can you imagine standing upright in a
crazy rubber suit in the wind and the
heat and everything at 70 miles an hour
wondering if you're gonna die
whereas I when I was on the real rig
which was like this wonderful fairground
ride that kind of shot us around it
brilliant fun but there I was wired on
to various bits of the scenery so that
with a certain latitude I couldn't go
further than that so I was totally safe
I had the best time ever are you doing
their appeal taking one last look
my friend there we are saying thanks for
listening to me talking about
c-3po not not so much today as a
character but as a costume and of course
as such I'm the actor who wears
something that's been created and
maintained and and fixed and fiddled
with and cared for and loved by a whole
team of people who have made this
character look so good and so convincing
in all the Star Wars films and both iron
Threepio was saying really guys and gals
you